how important is it for a creative to
have an agent or a manager
I think it's pretty you know
pretty important they help me I mean or
you know my manager helped me like uh he
was the one pushing the script out there
you know it gives you kind of a um
I don't know what the word is for it but
I don't want to say efficient like
making it official but like they're just
there's people I don't know you know and
like in order to get into the door with
these people like uh you know manager or
an agent is a good you know way to kind
of bridge that Gap because you know
someone who came in with like you know I
didn't know anybody so like how am I
supposed to am I supposed to show up and
you you know what I mean it's just like
you look like a crazy person and it
might work for somebody but
you know for me they were able to push
my my stuff out and get my name out
there so
well it could also hurt you I did that
when I was younger and I had my head
served to me on a platter so yeah you
don't want to overstep your bound
there's protocols exactly yeah exactly
you know what I mean so I was like man
what happened
but you know being young and foolish and
not knowing what I was doing I thought
that was okay but yeah yeah so there are
protocols um how long did it take you to
get representation
when did you represent something to
happen around
my first feature Rock Steady row that
was when
you know my manager approached me so
that was probably around 2000
17 or 18. yeah so about five years no no
yeah about five years ago or so
and approached you in an email or you
saw the person at a festival or uh he
called me because he was representing my
friend and then after I wrote the script
he called me in and and asked me
yeah okay so you he kind of already knew
your work through your friend yeah a
little bit yeah yeah what can an agent
or manager do for you that you can't do
on your own
um yeah again like
the you know knocking on doors and
getting the script out there you know
it's like it's you're a team
you know it's just like there's only so
much I can do on my own you know I'm not
saying I can't send the script to people
but it's like
you know how far is the reach you know
that I have and so uh them as a team
member to to help you do that and also
you know they give you feedback on what
the hell is going on in the industry you
know on how to like not necessarily how
to write your script but to tell you you
know necessarily maybe there's places
where you can take it you know there are
some places that don't make horror
movies okay so like the second you hear
they hear Horrors just like well we're
not the place for that you know and even
if they maybe are interested it's like
it you know so you you never know it's
just like so a manager helps you know
representation helps to kind of get that
in the right places and and the further
reach because you know you're only one
person so you know how far can you get
and even if you have the biggest name in
the world right you know it's like and
you know everybody you know even at the
smallest not to minimize their job to
this because they do a lot of other
stuff but you know it's like well you're
gonna sit in your room just like passing
it around all over the place like you
know that's it's a lot of time
you know so but outside of that you know
they do they help with that they help
with the reach
um they help you know shape your career
that you know they connect and like uh
pretty important to me
I'm wondering if we can go back to how
you met your manager so it was through a
collaborator and then they got your
number
yeah so
um I wrote a short film for my friend
and uh then the short film went online
and like and it did pretty well and that
got him contacted by you know a manager
the manager saw it and had a meeting
with him and then wanted to to represent
him
um
and then I continued working with him so
by by proxy I'm going to be you know
around this you know the manager for a
little bit or my manager so I was like I
was around you seeing me work with him
and then he finally read the feature
that I wrote from my friend and he was
like he liked what I did so he
um so you approached me on it
and so then you met in person eventually
or okay yeah yeah yeah was it just one
meeting in person and you signed with
him or you hadn't even met with him in
person you'd already signed
um it was a couple minutes I mean when
he approached me uh I'd be like oh I'd
like to represent you then yeah that one
was just one meeting but I had met with
him a couple different times because
during the process of me writing the
script he was giving notes and things of
that nature to me uh on the script or
whatever and like we were kind of in
conversation regardless so because of
that we had already had a few meetings
we had already engaged a little bit off
you know off the books or whatever so he
already kind of knew me by that time you
know by the time he approached me to
actually represent me
do pitch new ideas to your manager
before you write them uh yes yeah yeah
now yeah that's pretty much part of the
process like I'll tell them what I'm
thinking about you know these you know
because I have a you know have a little
book of ideas you know and I'll be like
hey these these ones are kinda
speaking to me right now uh and you know
we'll talk about it see which one we
feel like is
has the the best shot in which one I
feel the the strongest about you know
which I think
trumps like which has the best shot most
the time just because I'm you know I'm
gonna ride it out you know because I
love it so much so uh yeah
and so when you run it by him does he
look at it for marketability and for
sort of what he thinks some of these
networks would want or also he gauges
how interested you are I think it's a
combination of all those things you know
I think he's thinking about all those
things as
I think it's part of the gig you know
because he knows he's the one that knows
these people who he's going to push it
to so he's going to have his ideas on
why you know what he thinks is going to
be a cell or whatnot you know or at
least get you in the door you know
do you like Gatekeepers
or do they drive you crazy
oh well like people who say yes or no
basically right yeah
um I guess that's the definition of a
geek yeah yeah
um I mean I guess you have to always
have
a complicated relationship with them
right because they tell you no and they
also tell you yes right so
uh
yeah so I mean yes and no right no I
don't like I mean why would I like no
like you know it's like I wouldn't like
that part of a gatekeeper of course not
when you tell me no because I want to
push the idea through but you know when
you say yes then of course I'm gonna
like you you know I I guess I have to be
ambivalent about them right
well we all are Gatekeepers in a sense
yeah to our own whatever it is so you're
a gatekeeper and I'm a gatekeeper and
there's a geek but then we also have to
deal with other Gatekeepers so it's kind
of like we all become it
depending on what it is yeah I mean it's
a it's a tough job
to like be officially be like it you
know the person who's doing that it's a
tough racket so
um
it's hard to say like you know it's hard
to say like oh you know you're useless
or whatever like you know it's like I
don't want to say that because they have
like such a a tough gig you know they're
reading a bunch of stuff they're
watching a bunch of stuff and you know
people that are living a dime by their
well their projects with living or Dying
by this person and you know their
careers living and dying by it too uh so
um I don't know like it's uh it is it's
an interesting question and it's like I
have I guess I have mixed emotions on it
because human beings are so complex they
might just not something as simple as
not understanding your humor
you know it's just like there there's
different types of humor out there you
know when you're watching a Cohen's
brother movie or a Wes Anderson movie or
a Judd Apatow movie like these are
hitting you differently you know the
type of Comedy that these that these
guys are doing right
but someone might not understand one of
those types of humors and say no to it
and it's not has anything to do with you
personally or with your craft right so
you know how can I be upset at you for
not you know it's like understanding
something right so it I think it's
complicated
you were living in or near San
Bernardino County Redlands
did you think at one time you would be
living in La making movies was that
always part of your plan
I mean I think it slowly became part of
the plan I can't say that when I was
young I had dreams of living in LA and
making movies because it came to me late
like when I was 18 was when I
had the idea of like oh well maybe you
know because my mom gave it to me and
she saw me like editing stuff and was
like you know maybe you should do this
and so I was kind of pursuing it to see
what it means so you know but I didn't
have any understanding of like Hollywood
is where it happens right as I I didn't
know that I just knew that you know I
gotta make stuff and then as I learned
more and chased and went to like
Community College and then I was like
okay so now I'm going to USC now I'm in
Hollywood now I'm learning you know I
mean it's just like the more I learned
the more I was like oh okay so I gotta
kind of need to be here and need you
know you know I am here because I love
La in California but
um yeah it slowly became part of the the
journey you know and became a a part of
the goal you know
so you went to Community College in San
Bernardino for two years and then you
applied to USC and you knew okay once
you got in you'd be living up here
interesting yeah and so you did two
years you got your GE requirements yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's great
and how different was it was it was it
the same really to go to a community
college versus USC I mean community
colleges can be great there's a lot of
times it's very similar teachers yeah no
I was um it was definitely different uh
like you know access to resources
you know a huge difference like with you
know but as far as learning stuff you
know even learning stuff is like a
difference in in resources on what you
have you know like but at Valley College
you know but some of the fundamentals of
the stuff that I was learning in my
general education is stuff like are
still paying off dividends now that I
didn't learn at USC you know like one
just one of the most important classes I
took during while I was at San
Bernardino back it was a public speaking
class
still paying off
obviously yeah yeah you know it's still
paying off so like that wasn't something
I got at USC but you know it's like San
Bernardino had a film program that was
good that put a camera in my hand and
taught me Avid you know it's like so
like I got those skill sets but like at
USC you know it's just like I learned
how to shoot on film you know I learned
more about lighting you know it's like I
learned a little bit more about
storytelling I you know I was able to
even like the the the craft of directing
you you know it's like I I was able to
have access to some of these instructors
who were not necessarily at San
Bernardino Valley College not only
because of the distance but just the
resources
um and just like the focus to just be
like Oh I'm only here to be making short
films and then you know it's just like
in the net Valley College it's more of
like sure I'm taking the film program
but there are other people involved in
it that are you know this is just a an
elective they're not like you you know
what I mean so it's like I'm but like at
SC it's just like nah you are with
people who this is the this is the goal
you know we watch movies that's what we
do you know we make you know you're
around these people who are just kind of
like who are pushing you that way so
um it was definitely two different
experiences you know learning of course
like the bare minimum is like yeah
that's the same you're learning stuff
but the experience of both of them are
two they were two different things
and what about alumni assistance once
you graduate I mean are there other
people using each other for projects
even after you graduate or most people
are getting a job in the industry and so
they're not making films
um yeah I think a lot of people I mean
it's like you're saying like people
getting jobs interesting not making
movies with like what do you mean like
so it sounds like people they're still
making their own passion projects once
they get a job in the industry on
weekends or whatever are you part of an
alumni association or do they do they
kind of have a placement program to
something oh I mean I think I see had
like a job board that I was using for a
long time uh that got me jobs and stuff
like that uh which was cool and um I
mean definitely just like the people you
meet while you're at school like yeah
they hook you up like a lot of my
friends would hook me up with jobs
um and even now though like you know
because you have the connection like you
guys are sharing connections as well you
know to help each other out so
um yes you know it does this thing yeah
yeah I can remember going to La Festival
books and I'll see at least two
different film Crews you know just doing
things and it seems like they're part of
the film program
seems like a very active campus yeah
beautiful place yeah I loved it I
thought it was great I had a great time
yeah